well he's a lot more like everybody else
than anyone thinks you know the notion
that he's hitler or stella and that's
just foolish i don't see any evidence
for that at all i mean first of all
hitler and stellan were very singular
types and there's a bit of hitler and
stella and everyone so you know there's
some truth in that maybe there's more in
the typical russian language
really
there's more than a bit really
oh absolutely yeah well why would nazism
spread the way it did you know people
think well that's all top down it's not
top down
there's there's a part of people that
are all these people who informed on
kate burble saying well didn't go but
didn't goebbel say that the way to get
vast numbers of people to go along with
what you want to do is to terrify them
yeah well you can build a grip of terror
over them oh yeah but in a way that's
what putin's now doing with the russian
people where he's going back now into a
position of they're all trying to get us
they want to attack us they want to take
us over he's terrifying his people to
rally support for what at the moment is
a conflict he has started which is not
going the way he assumed well the most
uh what would you say the wisest
commentators on totalitarian states like
like solzhenitsyn
and and many psychological commentators
jung was a good example of that made a
very s straightforward case that you
can't have a totalitarian state unless
every single person is willing to lie
about everything all the time and you
can think about that as top down because
the leaders lie too and they also
enforce punishments if you don't lie but
then you can also think about it
the the totalitarian spirit is
replicated at every level of the society
and so in a truly totalitarian state
husbands lie to their wives and parents
lie to their children and the
totalitarian state is actually the grip
of the lie
and so
and and people will certainly go along
with that i mean i mean we're seeing
that emerge here with cancer culture
it's like lie yes or else yes it's like
yeah well and the russian people
will be bombarded all the time with
state media propaganda and we'll be
buying into a lot of what putin is
saying yeah
how does this war end you think
we're going to find out this winter well
i i i know what i would do in his shoes
i'd wait till the first cold snap and
shut off the taps right because he's
going to do that he's got the control
over the energy
of course he's going to do that he's
already warned the west with his
insistence that maintenance problems
were necessary and the pipelines
happened do you think he will use a
nuclear weapon
if necessary he'll use a tactical
battlefield weapon even if it starts
world war three it won't
probably why because we wouldn't respond
what's in it for us
if you let him do it and get away with
it
where does that end then you are under
here
look there's a lot you can get yourself
in a situation no problem where there's
no good outcome
we're trying to do that right now on
every front we can possibly imagine we
can easily get ourselves in a situation
where it's held this way and hell that
way that
that's highly probable should the
ukrainians give the russians anything
when i was over there recently
interviewing president zielinski what i
was struck by was everybody i met in
keys the capital city
were utterly resolute don't give them an
inch of our land yeah well i don't i
can't speak to that because i don't know
what the preconditions for peace might
be but i do know that
naive notions that the russians are
going to lose somehow or that we're
going to win
i i don't i just don't understand i
don't understand that well what do you
mean we're going to win what are we
going to win here exactly well i guess a
victory would be that the russians
retreated from ukraine
with with ukrainian runes
right well
that's a hell of a victory like i think
putin could manage that because i think
he could tell his people
and i think they might buy it it's like
we accomplished our objective we
devastated ukraine and we kept it out of
the hands of the west and that's not
great
it's not what we'd hoped for but
it's better than the alternative and i
think they would buy that and i think
when putin went into ukraine i thought
well i thought a bunch of things which i
i made a youtube video about that people
criticized like matt i thought okay well
what's happening here oh i see
his his end game for failure is that
right that ukraine is left in a smoking
rune oh that's a victory
so
then he can lose with impunity right so
how can we win
we can't win against
vladimir putin anyways because
you cannot win against someone you
cannot say no to period
and we can't say no to putin because
we sold our soul for his oil and gas
and we did that to elevate our moral
stature in relationship to saving the
planet and so
here we are yeah facing a very dire
winter
hoisted on the patard of our own
foolishness and moral presumption
we're saving the planet
we'll see i don't think so
it doesn't look like it to me and this
is this is the most catastrophic issue
here assuming that we're facing an
environmental
crisis of planetary proportions which is
not something i buy by the way
assuming we are well then i would
imagine that you would put in place
measures that would
ameliorate that problem
instead of exacerbating it but all the
measures you're putting in place are
actually making the environmental
problem worse
so
how is that even vaguely acceptable and
i look at that and i think oh i see it's
just like george orwell said about
middle-class socialists 50 years ago
it's not that you love the planet it's
that you hate humanity
so
well have at her boys and girls and
we'll see what happens this winter and
it's very terrifying to me
especially here
you know because your energy prices have
gone way out of control and that's going
to hurt a lot of poor people and and
certainly around the world as well the
world bank already estimated that we put
350 million people into what they call a
food insecurity
350 million that's three times as many
as the communists managed to kill maybe
we can manage that in the winter but the
planet has too many people on it anyway
so you know that's just poor people
you